un posible avance en las conversaciones
los puertos de ucrania podrían reabrirse
por primera vez desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa ya que un acuerdo para
reanudar las exportaciones de kiev por
el mar negro está listo para ser firmado
entre los enviados ucranianos y rusos
los detalles del acuerdo se han
mantenido en secreto pero los
diplomáticos han dicho que el plan
incluye que rusia acepte una tregua
local mientras se mueven los envíos que
los barcos de granos sean guiados por
los buques ucranianos a través de las
aguas portuarias minadas los barcos
también se someterán a la inspección de
turquía acordada por la onu y así se
podrá reducir los temores rusos de
contrabando de armas y finalmente la
unión europea y eeuu facilitarán las
exportaciones rusas de granos y
fertilizantes la onu y turquía llevan
meses trabajando para llegar a un
acuerdo ya que unas 20 millones de
toneladas de grano están atascados en
los silos de odessa pero los
funcionarios ucranianos se mostraron
cautelosos ante el acuerdo por temor a
cambios de última hora por parte de
rusia
el hecho es que hasta la fecha rusia ha
convertido en armas los alimentos
durante este conflicto acogemos con
satisfacción el anuncio de este acuerdo
en principios pero lo que nos centramos
ahora en responsabiliza a la bruja de la
utilización de acuerdos de permitir que
el grano no llegue
el acuerdo podría contribuir a aliviar
la crisis alimentaria mundial que ha
disparado los precios de los cereales y
ha dejado a millones de personas en todo
el mundo en riesgo de padecer hambre